[Music]
on this tuesday night covet vaccination
persuasion there are enough doses for
everyone so
why are vaccinations dropped off we need
to continue
to make sure that people are getting
vaccinated why some people are
hesitant and how life could get harder
for the unbaxed
mounting backlash against the montreal
canadiens perhaps management is still
choosing to look the other way
the impact of choosing a player who's
also an admitted sex offender
allegations dating back decades the
criminal investigation into sexual abuse
at a manitoba residential school
and women for the win the canadian
olympians
muscling up more medals in tokyo
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a push to escalate
kobit 19 vaccinations in canada
uptake has been great for months but now
it's dropped off
even though there are more than enough
doses for everyone
canada now has 66 million vaccine doses
in the country enough to provide
two shots to all eligible canadians and
more than 48 million doses have already
been administered
80 percent of eligible canadians over
the age of 12 had have received at least
one dose
64 have had both doses the trick
now is to convince the rest of those
eligible to get their shots
vacs to the max is the strategy launched
in bc today using persuasion rather than
coercion
canadians aren't being forced to get the
vaccine but anyone who doesn't
could end up with limits on what they
can do and where they can go
mike lacature has our top story tonight
well if everyone else gets vaccinated
they will be kept safe
you will not be safe that pointed
warning from prime minister justin
trudeau
aimed at people who are hoping to be
protected by herd immunity
instead of a vaccine canada's
vaccination rate was
on a steady climb but the summer has
seen a steep slide in daily doses
administered
for 100 people it's why politicians are
prodding canadians
to get jabbed different provinces are
looking at incentive programs we're
certainly working
with the provinces on documentation to
facilitate international travel as
more and more countries like canada has
just done
is going to open only to fully
vaccinated travelers
trudeau warns the delta variant is still
circulating and the majority of new
cases
are among the unvaccinated in wednesday
and on that day we will open all our
clinics to just walk in capacity
bc is waiving appointments for one day
next week as the province ramps up its
immunization campaign
while case counts rise but health
experts say governments
still have some work to do in fighting
the misinformation
online and convincing the roughly 20
percent of canadians
who are still not vaccinated treat
people who have questions
in a serious manner we're not is this
not the time for shaming and blaming or
finger pointing that does nothing but
further polarize the situation
the next step after persuasion could be
coercion
following in the footsteps of france
which will deny
access to indoor venues if you are not
vaccinated
it's an approach quebec has hinted it
could use
if another lockdown is necessary and it
may get people out to a certain
demographic to get vaccinated
as a way to mitigate the risk and to
really just not deal with the
inconvenience of not going there
bc health minister adrian dicks reminded
residents about the measles outbreak two
years ago
saying children who weren't protected
against that disease
weren't allowed back to school warning
in this pandemic
there are consequences to not being
vaccinated
donna all right michael couture in
ottawa thanks
canada is due to open its border to
fully vaccinated
travelers from the united states in just
under two weeks and
now canada border services agency
workers are threatening to walk off the
job
the union representing nine thousand
cbsa workers has voted in favor of a
strike
it could happen as soon as august six
three days before the border reopens
many of the workers are deemed essential
though so the border wouldn't close
completely but there could be long
delays
the workers have been without a contract
for three years talks between the two
sides fell apart in
december americans are dealing with
rising cases of covid19
a pandemic of the unvaccinated and now
the u.s centers for disease control has
reversed its guidance on masks
it is recommending fully vaccinated
people return to wearing masks
indoors in areas with high transmission
rates the highly contagious delta
variant is the dominant one
in the u.s now new scientific evidence
shows
even fully vaccinated people may become
infected and may carry as much virus
as those who are unvaccinated and they
could transmit it
our message to the american public is
we are at war we continue to be at war
with a virus
an evolving pandemic our responsibility
here
is to always lead with the science and
always lead with the
advice of health and medical experts
the japanese capital is dealing with a
record number of kobit 19 cases
and the timing couldn't be worse just
four days into the summer
olympics tokyo is reporting more than 2
800 new infections
the city's highest daily count that's
more than double the number of cases
reported
last tuesday the highly transmissible
delta variant
is also driving the rapid spread there
the world's best gymnast american simone
biles withdrew from today's olympic
competition surprising everyone
we'll have more on that coming up plus
canada's biggest day on the podium yet
gold in weightlifting and
an historic victory in women's softball
but first things aren't so golden for
the montreal canadiens at the moment
since the team drafted a player who has
admitted to sharing sexually explicit
photos of a woman without her consent
the criticism keeps mounting he is 18
and says he regrets it
but for many fans and team sponsors
that's not good enough
mike armstrong explains fans of the
montreal canadiens for weeks
wore almost a perpetual smile as the
team's playoff push took them all the
way to the nhl finals
with our 31st pick overall in the end
friday night with this pick
it appears the good will it had gathered
is gone
logan may you it shocked even the
announcers
all right well this is something the
league probably wishes didn't happen but
now it has happened
may you right point winds up takes the
shot towards that and he scores
now mayu is a defenseman out of ontario
but last year while playing in sweden
the 17 year old took photographs of a
young woman during a sexual encounter
and shared them with teammates picking a
player with that past has
major habs sponsors perplexed the saint
jabel restaurant chain
jankutsu pharmacies and the desjardins
financial group
all say they're evaluating their
partnership with the team
the have's highest profile fan is
weighing in as well
as a lifelong habs fan i have to say
i am deeply disappointed by the decision
i think it was a
lack of judgment by the canadians
organization he's a young man
who made a serious mistake the canadians
gm
did try to do some damage control over
the weekend promising to help maiu with
counseling
i deeply regret it himself also spoke
out
i know i cause a lot of harm to this
person and their family
i think the decision itself is really
really disappointing
alone is a women's rights advocate one
of the things she does is visit schools
to talk about how
damaging sharing nudes can be drafting
maiushi says undercuts that work
like that absolutely um sets us back in
terms of our conversations with
young people we cannot underestimate the
message that this sends
let's not forget about the victim here
yeah if the canadians were hoping the
goodwill they'd collected from the
playoffs would help this controversy
blow over
it hasn't instead the storm
may still be growing mike armstrong
global news
montreal
this is the former fort alexander
residential school in manitoba where for
decades
indigenous children from 21 communities
were forced to go
the rcmp confirmed today that in 2010
they began
investigating allegations of sexual
abuse here
the scope of the criminal investigation
has meant combing through archival
records and taking witness statements
it is sensitive complex work brittany
greenslade explains what's underway and
why it's only coming to light now
brittany
donna a manitoba first nation is once
again dealing with the pain and trauma
of residential schools this time in the
form of a decade-long
criminal investigation launched by the
rcmp that's only now coming to light
manitoba rcmp confirmed its officers
have spent more than 10 years
investigating alleged sexual abuse
at the fort alexander residential school
on sagging first nation
northwest of winnipeg mounties say
they've poured over archived school
records in manitoba and ottawa
and interviewed more than 700 people
across north america
gathering 75 witness and victim
statements
evidence that is now in the hands of
crown prosecutors
so far no charges have been laid the
fort alexander residential school closed
in 1970.
survivors spoke to the truth and
reconciliation commission about abuse
starvation and harsh discipline
including the former grand chief of the
assembly of manitoba chiefs phil
fontaine
who disclosed his own sexual abuse at
the facility
sagging first nation chief derek
henderson says it's been
an extremely difficult few days for his
community which also just began radar
searches for
possible unmarked graves in a statement
henderson says
we ask that the trauma our community has
experienced and continues to live every
day
is respected and that those affected are
afforded their privacy
at this time 14 different residential
schools operated throughout manitoba
manitoba rcmp say this is the only one
under investigation
donna okay brittany greenslade in
winnipeg tonight thanks
today prince edward island became the
fourth canadian jurisdiction to reach a
child care deal with the federal
government
the plan aims to lower fees to 10 a day
by the end of 2024.
the federal government will contribute
more than 121 million
over five years bc nova scotia and yukon
all have reached child care deals with
ottawa earlier this month
reliving the violence of january 6th
coming up police officers describe the
trauma of being caught in the
insurrection
on capitol hill plus the first person
charged under hong kong's security law
learns his fate
as i was swarmed by a violent mob they
ripped off my badge
they grabbed and stripped me of my radio
they seized ammunition that was secure
to my body
they began to beat me with their fists
and with what felt like hard metal
objects
that is one of the police officers who
survived the attack on the u.s capitol
in washington in january
nearly seven months later we're hearing
harrowing first-hand accounts from
officers of what they endured
when that mob of trump supporters
stormed the building
the officers are the first to testify at
an inquiry into the riot
jackson proskow has more on what they
said and a warning
his story does contain strong language
and graphic video
so help you god inside the building they
bravely defended
four frontline officers became the first
to testify in the official inquiry
into the insurrection they quelled i
heard people in the crowd yelling
get his gun kill him with his own gun i
was effectively defenseless and
gradually sustaining injury
from the increasing pressure of the mob
in harrowing detail they relived the
events of january
6th the riders attempted to reach the
capitol were shouting
trump sent us pick
the right side they detailed the
physical and emotional scars they
suffered
and the racial abuse they faced at the
hands of the pro-trump
mob one woman in a pink mega shirt
yelled
you hear that guys this voted for joe
biden
then the crowd perhaps around 20 people
joined in screaming boo
the officers also addressed the elephant
not in the room
the republicans still loyal to trump
who've downplayed the attempt to
violently overturn the election
the indifference shown to my colleagues
is disgraceful long before it began
the january 6th commission was bogged
down by politics
republicans torpedoed an independent
inquiry
and attempted to stack the congressional
committee with insurrection denialists
who are rejected by democrats
nancy pelosi was made aware of potential
security threats to the capitol
and she failed to act the only
republican voices on the committee are
from those who refuse to blindly defend
trump
or back the lie about a stolen election
you talk about the impact of that day
but you guys won
you guys held as the commission begins
its work
they face retribution from within their
own party for seeking an
honest investigation the officers who
testified believe that any investigation
must include a full accounting of who
incited
and coordinated the attack that includes
probing the uncomfortable question
of whether any of the lawmakers they're
sworn to protect
may have been involved in the events of
that day donna
jackson in washington thanks in hong
kong the first person charged under a
controversial national
security law has been convicted and a
warning some of the footage
may be disturbing
tong ying kit was arrested for this he
drove his motorcycle around hong kong
last july carrying a flag with an
anti-government slogan and
colliding with police officers three of
them were injured
he has been found guilty of terrorism
and inciting secession
and he faces the possibility of life in
prison under the new law tong was denied
bail
and a jury trial it is widely criticized
as beijing's move to stifle free speech
protests and hong kong's pro-democracy
movement
nearly 140 people have been arrested
under the national security law
many of them are students activists and
journalists
calls for accountability still ahead one
woman's pledge to improve the quality of
life
for residents in long-term care
you're watching global national
[Music]
it's now well known that the first wave
of the pandemic hit residents in
long-term care homes the hardest
the majority of people who died of covid
19 in canada were living
in long-term care their families are
still grieving
and an ontario woman who lost her mother
is vowing to keep fighting
for change in a system she calls corrupt
karen lieberman has her story she lost
her will to live
she didn't want to live in that
environment anymore
maureen mcdermott dreaded the day she
could no longer care for her 91 year old
mother at home
with alzheimer's disease and other
complex medical needs
she decided long-term care was the only
option
elsie entered river glen haven nursing
home in december 2019.
i felt like she was safe where she was
and then she wasn't covid19 crept into
long-term care facilities across the
country
targeting society's most vulnerable
seniors
like elsie my mother on mother's day
was diagnosed positive with covet a
total of 36 would die at this one home
in sutton ontario
during the first wave of the pandemic
residents of nursing and seniors homes
accounted for more than 80 percent of
all reported covid19 deaths in canada
elsie survived the virus but the
conditions the pandemic created took a
toll
it was like 10 years happened in 106
days
to be denied to love her and
hold her and give her some hope how
would you describe
the system it's driven by a group
that have very little to do with the
inside operations of long-term care in a
statement the ceo of atk care group
which owns river glen haven said as we
continue to learn more about this virus
we will continue to make operational
changes for the health and safety of
staff
residents and families in may mcdermott
lost her mother
by then she says there was little of
elsie left
she said this isn't living maureen this
is only
existing in her mother's memory a vow to
keep fighting
it started with this meeting with
ontario's new minister of long-term care
who has promised to build 30 000 new
beds in the next decade
and update legislation to enhance
accountability measures
i don't envy him or anybody stepping
into the role in the mess
that was left by the previous minister
but i'm i'm hopeful
change she says would be elsie's legacy
karen lieberman global news
toronto
winning women up next the athletes
adding to canada's olympic glory at the
tokyo games
in a stunning move the star of the u.s
women's gymnastics squad pulled out of
the artistic team final today simone
biles says
she needs to focus on her mental health
the 24 year old withdrew after just
one rotation she says a shaky vault made
her realize she wasn't
in the right headspace bile says she
didn't want to jeopardize her health and
well-being or risk a medal for her team
the rest of her team did go on to win
silver
the team representing the russian
olympic committee took gold it's unclear
if biles will compete in her five
other events which include defending her
all-round title
on thursday japanese tennis star naomi
osaka was knocked out of the women's
tournament today and a huge upset
osaka who was ranked second lost in the
third round
the olympic tournament was her first
major competition in nearly two months
after she sat out both the french open
and wimbledon
to focus on her mental health japan is
still leading the way
in gold medals here's a look at where
things stand japan has 10
goals now the us and china each have
nine
canada has two and is ranked eighth
overall
one of those golds was won today in
weight lifting it capped off
a four medal day for canadian athletes
this country also won its first ever
olympic softball medal a bronze
crystal commencing breaks down another
big day for canada
pride on full display the metals
stacking up with bronze silver
and gold hanging around the necks of
canadians mulch out all of quebec
muscling the second gold for canada it
was a very
great competition good battle it was
a nice competition surely to watch
to do as well and i'm very proud charon
was
tearful as the anthem played in her
honor
only one other canadian has won olympic
gold for weightlifting
catherine bushman pinard earned canada's
second
ever olympic medal in judo like jessica
klimkate's winning match on monday
buschmann pinard captured bronze in
sudden death
for the canadian women's softball team
they've forged
new territory winning canada's first
olympic softball medal when they
defeated mexico
3-2 for bronze unlike softball swimming
is an
area of dominance for canada ontario's
kylie moss was
just off the olympic record-setting pace
swimming the 100-meter backstroke in
57.72 seconds
after capturing silver she said she's
been inspired by her fellow swimmers
it's incredibly powerful to see someone
else succeed it makes you want to be a
part of it and
it creates this atmosphere that's
electric and
um it and so positive so watching the
girls win the silver
watching maggie win gold um it's so
motivating
watching these young talented driven
athletes
is a huge draw and people are finding
ways to get their olympic fill
despite spectators being banned we don't
feel at least at risk
for being outside and i mean as you can
tell
people are keeping their distance
wearing masks
fearing groups gathering while cases of
covet 19 surge
in tokyo the prime minister urged people
to stay home
and watch the olympics on tv it's a
problem that could get worse as more
japanese athletes win medals and the
games become a bigger draw
for locals crystal gomanson global news
london and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is sand lake in the town of
kearny ontario we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you